Chiefs tight-end Travis Kelce joins us
thanks to Old Spice the official sweat
defense of the NFL offering guys old new
Old Spice sweat defense dry spray and a
push but was superior 48-hour sweat and
odor protection for more info check out
the Old Spice YouTube channel there is
Travis Kelly handsome and smelling so
good really delightful thanks to Old
Spice I've loved working with Old Spice
over the years they've given me all the
grooming products that I could ever need
this year they've got me on the Old
Spice sweat defense anti Spurs
antiperspirant spray it being 48 hours
of sweat and odor protection the
official antiperspirant of the NFL Old
Spice always always come in through oh
well well said you are quite the
endorser there way to go man what a
professional they must be paying you a
lot of money hey he's got that red Old
Spice t-shirt on do you have one of
those I got one no I don't Lea I'm not
big big-time enough that I get a red
fits-him but yeah I got yeah rock yo you
do okay all right Travis has been a
strange few days give me the best way to
describe your emotions the team's
mindset after the Patrick mahomes injury
well I think the biggest thing that we
had to do is um is keep our composure
during the game at least and then
afterwards we're all kind of just
keeping our fingers crossed that Pat's
gonna be all right not only be able to
get back some time soon but get back
healthy and be able to play the game you
know the way he knows how to so that's
that's probably the biggest thing is
just to make sure that we don't act
uncharacteristically here going forward
everyone just does their job when we um
we keep trying to win football games
what was said what was done on the
sidelines to get everyone to keep their
composure during that game um really it
was just everyone having confidence that
that mat could come in and win that
football game for us and and you could
see it and everyone's eyes no-one there
wasn't a hiccup there wasn't anyone
anyone tripping over their feet as soon
as Matt came in he said listen we got
that in and then and everyone rallied
with them and you know Matt Moore can
dice it up and then where if we if we
move forward and and have to win
few ballgames with him I got all the
confidence in world we can do that I
mean my heart hurt when I saw him on the
ground like I was hurt like as a fan
okay like in your head do you have weak
moments like that when he first seen him
down are you like oh my gosh mahomes is
down oh my gosh were in deep trouble
like well I give us some raw Travis
Kelce brain there is that's going down
it went down and and he was at the he
wasn't at the bottom of the pile but he
was in the pile and he couldn't move and
everyone's kind of just wondering like
why isn't he getting up and then he
pointed at his knee and it didn't look
like a knee and just as his brother as
his friend man I thought I'm a Patrick
my homes fan just as a person right so I
that being you know the moment where it
was just like man I hope I hope my
brother's all right man I hope he could
just you know whatever it is he gets
over and he gets healthy fast but let's
go out here and win this game for him
and let him know we got his back
mad Moore's not Patrick my Holmes no
one's packed from homes right now Travis
but what's the best thing that Matt
Moore brings to the table for the Chiefs
offense on his experience his experience
and believe it or not at the quarterback
position that that means a lot
especially especially in this offense
where we're asking a quarterback to do a
lot of things and I think Matt came in
handled the game correctly finished this
off and then and on top of that you know
moving forward we're just gonna have to
keep chugging along like I said when
guys start to act uncharacteristically
that's when you're in trouble we got a
lot of great players in this locker room
that feed off of each other and and I
think Matt's gonna come in and do just
fine like you did you know you talked
about the character in your locker room
and I'm curious about this because you
guys have been such an offensive
football team for the last two years and
you know listen I work Johnny media guys
over here yeah the defense for you guys
is not exactly held up its end of the
bargain right at least that's what it
looks like to us a touch how do you guys
you know stop from me in locker room
fighting that you see from some teams at
time to time when one side of the ball
is clearly performing you know at a much
higher level than the other side of the
ball um
I think one thing that's helped that is
the the the GM bringing in guys with
good character guys with that are
unselfish they understand the game and
that it's not always gonna go our way
he's brought in guys with the right
mentality and and that's helped us even
through the past three games where we
lost two and had a lot of adversity and
in this last one but we just we play
together man we play together we love
each other for what it is and we're and
we always know we're going to go battle
with whoever's out there on that field
and I also think that winning helps that
some some la Cruz keep pretty crazy when
you start losing but we kept it together
during the two games that we lost and
Travis we saw the defense find a new
level on Thursday night against the
Broncos how much of that in your
estimation was a reaction to the Patrick
mahomes injury or how much of it was
gonna happen anyway against the Broncos
um I think I think it was just a
determined mindset that they were gonna
stop the run and once we stopped that
early we made it pretty difficult on
them to to stay in the pocket and I mean
as an offense if you can't run the ball
and your quarterbacks getting rushed I
mean that's it it's gonna be a long day
for you how about this week you got a
big one
okay I'm hurt because I wanted to see
Rodgers in the homes mahomes and Rodgers
you know Rodgers is like the original
mahomes what like what's your thought on
Rodgers have you played against them
before and if sober it's not whatever
what is your kind of over overview of
him as a football player the one time I
remember playing him was in Lambeau a
few years back but he he put up like 40
on us and it was a hug he touched us up
pretty good so I'm hoping that uh we get
out there and throw some points up on
him knowing that he's an arrowhead this
time but I think Erin's a great guy
great player obviously one of the best
ever doing man he um he plays the game
with a lot of flair to him and which is
uh which is always fun to watch but he's
coming in Arrowhead and and we're gonna
try and get fired up and and rattle him
just a little bit Travis how much of a
sense of urgency to win at home on
Sunday night after losing two in a row
at Arrowhead you know what I think I
think it's just motivation to
in front of our fans man we got the best
fan base in the world baby the the Red
Sea is always rocking it's always going
and they deserve a hard-fought win on
Sunday night when the lights are on
does it feel different on Sunday night
when you know that everyone's watching
it's a bigger game it's a big spot it's
almost like a playoff atmosphere when
you're playing on Sunday Night Football
without a doubt and it kind of took me a
while to really match the feeling of it
being the kind of a playoff type of game
and it's a whenever the lights are on
man everyone everyone's watching
literally everyone's watching so you
just gotta you got to go out there and
try not to do too much just be yourself
in and and play your tail out for your
brother buddy it's it's definitely a
little bit different feeling and uh and
get you going a little bit more all
right
let's like just get into life a little
you had a long weekend because you
played Thursday night what you do I mean
anything fun this weekend you just sit
on the couch what went down tomorrow
I went back to the University of
Cincinnati where I was there for five
years playing both quarterback and tight
end back in 2009 we went 12 know during
the regular season and and everybody on
that team got recognized into the and
inducted to the Cincinnati Hall of Fame
so it was good to see all my Bearcat
brothers all the family back there
that's still making that place as
special as it is and sure enough
Cincinnati got the wood over Tulsa shout
out to the cats baby
wow you are big-time because they
orchestrated that whole event around you
and your schedule that's and you know
your big time they look the schedule and
saw Thursday game they said Travis can
be there that weekend and we didn't know
what it was it was it was the fact that
Brian Kelly the head coach at the time
they scheduled it around him you're
right he might be bigger time than you
you're right that might have won out I
didn't play much back you know night and
we do need to correct one thing as Phil
Simms who's from Eastern Kentucky has
told Chris over again it's not
Cincinnati it's since Aneta gotta get it
right University of Cincinnati all right
Travis we'll check out the old spite you
spiced YouTube channel and the new Old
Spice sweat defense dry spray and a
purse but thanks buddy all the best this
weekend beyond oh it's good seeing you
guys
you too buddy see you man
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports